c'est grégory basso
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire du porno ensemble quoi un
film de charme clip de charme il connaît
pas avec moi et journée avec laeticia
qu'on a vu c'était donc le bachelor
de ballons si c'était n'importe où les
gens qui font de la télé réalité en fait
il faut en effet c'est quoi bein de
charme c'est charlie blocher dans un
film de charme c'est un film qui passe
sur m6 en deuxième partie de soirée on
mène pas à un ami commun qui les attend
et retient on voit les poêles ou pas
dans les normes non on demande justement
qui est beaucoup de toile pour justement
que ça camoufle au cas où c'est
peut-être qu'ils jouaient dans la touffe
quelque chose
arrivait dans la tour du qatar explique
madani donc vous vous connaissez vous
vous êtes vus
contre une fois comme ça au pardon
tournage faisait un reportage en fait
ouais je suis un reportage et
ouais il jouait le photographe voilà je
vais jouer le photographe et je me
rappelle que les filles venaient me voir
en disant dany s'il te plaît tu me
passer de la crème la crème pailleté et
lui regarder comme ça et collants qui
pendait en
gaule et
10 mois alors désormais et n hésitez
plus greg le millionnaire mais est ce
que tu es toujours millionnaire toujours
pas même en roupies non je suis comédien
arrêtez vos conneries les comédiens
parce que messi et ses séides et
comédien c'est pas un jeu ce coup-ci un
cépage jourdain ma gueule d'ailleurs
c'est la fiche que tu as oui
bonsoir bonsoir se bâtit comédiens dix
mois aux médias comment tu fais alors
produire ton texte sandero [ __ ] à la
fin de chaque phrase figure tools est
assez facile en fait et je perds même
mon accent parfois sur scène apparemment
mais j'ai travaillé pour ça je me suis
enfermé pendant un mois avec gérard
winter qui était mon mentor et qui m'a
dit mon ami plein de cerveau qui me fait
un bourrage de crâne et j'ai énormément
galères et c'était vraiment difficile
parce que j'ai appris que la comédie
c'est un métier et ce métier super dur
concerne provis pas comédien comme ça il
m'a dit maintenant la plus grosse fierté
c'est d'être sur les planches tous les
jours de jouer en live au théâtre de
trévise est il de voir à la fin du
spectacle les gens nous faire trois
quatre voire cinq rappels tous les soirs
et puis et puis sortir avec le sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles et ma plus grande
fierté c'est simple voile alors la pièce
s'appelle qu'on tire bien sûr les lapins
a déjà parlé ici mais c'était pas encore
toi qui l'interprétait c'est une pièce
écrite et interprétée par gérard painter
avec mot de bouquets et toi donc six
recrues devront désormais alors c'est
l'histoire d'un lapin qui dure 2 partout
non donc alors c'est quoi le pitch
l'histoire mais c'est l'histoire d'un
mec plutôt d'un groupe de mecs qui
rentrent de vacances d'une croisière et
qui se retrouve qu'on essaie dans un
aéroport avec une valise de coqs qui
leur appartiennent pas oui
hélas il est naturel il revient au galop
c'est pas un rôle de composition est
mais je vous rappelle que l'été que que
la pièce a été écrite pour moi elle
existait quand même l'année dernière
donc ouais voilà et en l'occurrence il
ya des mafieux colombien qui arrive qui
commence à les intimider qui meurent des
balles perdues des flics complètement
psychopathe
du raid qui a qu'une envie c'est tirer
son coup avant de rentrer dans sa
caserne dans la creuse et un agent de
propreté qui finit un petit peu
sado-masochistes vois ça tu fais le flic
je fais deux flics je fais le flic
psychopathe l'agent du raid je joue le
rôle du mafieuse joue le rôle de xavier
un vendeur du les deux dealers colombien
lundi dont deux propre beauté qu'à une
[ __ ] en faire nous voilà il paraît pas
ce qu'elle fit du bruit apparemment
demandé
tu connais orlando ouais
et alors tu en penses quoi je veux dire
quand magnéto peu comme à la rigueur
mais pourquoi parce qu'il exige le clip
alors là tu regarde ta caméra
magnéto serge c'était la bonne caméra
c'était pas la bonne caméra c'est celle
qu'elle rouge c'est en tout cas ce gars
bellaoui vas-y
magnéto serge
on va prendre un pitch in a mis
la fille
aux yeux
revolver
je ne m'abuse et canal
se sont plu major alors mettre la ville
du port
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
il ya
bien sûr les latins jupp heynckes heures
au théâtre trévise avec maud bouquet et
grégory basso qui est notre invité ce
soir voilà c'est bien non bah oui je
trouve ça formidable j'ai quand même
plaisir je suis emballé parce que je
suis un petit peu au tac excusez moi
parce que ça me fait vraiment ça me
tenait à coeur de commencer là dedans
genre winter est venu vers moi m'a
proposé ça et
il m'a tout appris et je suis content
qu'on m'ait donné la chance d'être au
théâtre tous les soirs et je me régale
quoi je vais vous amène à tous la télé
réalité finalement ben ouais mais
finalement tu vois ça m'a ouvert des
portes mais voilà alors bon il ya cette
carrière de comédien qui quand même déjà
assez extraordinaire tu en conviendras
laurent et oui ça sent le molière
le plus extraordinaire tu crois pas si
bien dire turin pas si bien dire le plus
extraordinaire c'est que le 22 novembre
grégory part à new york pour les emmy
awards emmy awards faut savoir que c'est
la récompense mondiale des programmes de
télévision et il se trouve que greg le
millionnaire oui voilà est nominée aux
emmy awards c'est incroyable du jour
ça me fait plaisir en fait mais ce qui
me fait le plus plaisir c'est qu'à la
base c'est un concept américain way qui
a été adapté donc par la france et
depuis qu'ils ont vu les images ils ont
toujours vendu avec les images française
de gaston et que c'est un processus un
programme français qui va représenter
une chaîne américaine
ça fait plaisir quand même et je pense
que la plus fière de tout cela llorente
ma productrice ça lui fait plaisir et
c'est
quand tu vas aller à new york tu va
visiter la maison blanche à washington
et je crois bien
ouais
aller
annick et marjolaine avec ça tu sais
quoi
alors dit moi non sérieusement il ya un
truc à new york quand même ses lecteurs
studio tu es d'accord et j'ai commencé
des cours acteur studio à paris
justement
lee strasberg c'est à new york qu'il
était du coup je crois qu'on va faire
une interview acteur studio
[Musique]
alors est ce que tu pourrais nous jouer
la peur
la savoie y était la colère
non c'est pas mal tiré oui c'est pas mal
est ce que tu pourrais jouer le
millionnaire malheureux de ne pas
trouver la femme de sa vie
enfin je trouve que les sentiments il
passe le gigolo joue le gigolo pauvres à
un homme qui dit je t'aime avec les yeux
avec la baie james
est ce que tu peux nous jouer l'homme
qui veut faire comprendre à une femme
qu'il avait là tout de suite maintenant
tu l'as si ce
n'était pas le gorille on recommence à
temps même s'il te plaît là tu as joué
l'homme qui vient de manger de l'ail
rien à voir
non fait nous chez nous fait nous le
truc c'est le sérieusement ça les gêne
apparemment je n'aime pas du tout les
comédiennes comme toi enfin que je la
mange maintenant non pas que tu vas
mange que tu la regardes jeu ici c'est
manger aussi
alors maintenant on voit la chine où
l'acteur kahn a marre de ne pas être
pris au sérieux
tu as vu la palette des mecs ça vu
l'appareil est ce que tu peux nous jouer
l'inquiétude de la star devant le voici
du lundi matin
venez jouer la fleur qui pousse
à john faire le tueur
[Musique]
silencieux [ __ ] coûte le tueur je le
fais tous les soirs au théâtre alors
viens me voir au théâtre de trévise du
mardi au samedi à 20h et j'invite tout
le monde à venir nous voir parce que
c'est vraiment marrant vous allez vous
éclater c'est une comédie à mourir de
rire sérieusement faut venir ou pas
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux